- [Voiceover] Calculate the pH
at the half-equivalence point.
So, let's just remind ourselves
what the half-equivalence point even is.
The equivalence point is when the titrant,
in this case the hydrochloric acid,
completely reacts with
the potassium sorbate,
the thing that we are titrating.
Now the half-equivalence
point is the point
at which half of the potassium sorbate
has been converted to the sorbic acid.
Or another way of thinking about it is,
the concentrations of
the potassium sorbate
and the sorbic acid are equivalent.
Well, how do we relate that to pH,
and what other information
have they given us
to actually solve this?
And a good thing to do whenever you are,
if you feel a little bit stuck here, say,
"Well, what other information
have they given us?"
Well, they gave us the K-a of sorbic acid
is being 1.7 times ten
to the negative fifth.
So somehow, can we connect
the K-a of sorbic acid
to the pH at the half-equivalence point?
Well the other thing that they give you,
is they give you a whole
series of formulas.
In fact, they give you all the formulas
that I'm using here in
the first couple of pages
of the free-response section,
and even a whole bunch of formulas
on equilibria and all of these
different notations they use.
And the one that might show
up that looks interesting
is this one right over here
that you might recognize
as the Henderson-Hasselbalch equation.
And it's actually not hard to prove it.
It comes straight out of the definition
of K-a, and then rearranging things,
and then taking the negative log
of both sides and doing things like that.
I encourage you to watch those videos
on Khan Academy if you are curious,
but what's neat here is it connects pH,
it connects pH, it connects pH, to p-K-a,
and the concentrations of an acid
and its conjugate base.
So how do we make a relationship here?
Well, at the half-equivalence point,
the acid in the conjugate base are gonna,
their concentrations are
going to be equivalent.
So this, and this are going to cancel out.
You're just gonna get one.
And log of one is just going to be zero.
So, at the half-equivalence
point, the pH is going
to be equal to the p-K-a.
And so what is the p-K-a here?
Well, they told us that the K-a,
the K-a is equal to,
and this is the K-a of sorbic acid,
K-a of sorbic acid is 1.7 times ten
to the negative fifth.
1.7 times ten to the negative fifth.
And once again, when
we're thinking about K-a
we're thinking about the
dissociation constant
for the acid, and so that's
why we used sorbic acid there.
And, either way, these two
concentrations are going
to be the same.
And if I want to find the p-K-a,
I take the negative log of...
I take the negative log of this.
So, p-K-a, which is equal
to the negative log, base ten, of the K-a.
And they actually give
you all these formulas
on the first page.
This is going to be equal
to the negative log,
base ten, of 1.7 times ten
to the negative fifth power.
And what is that going to be?
Let me get a calculator out.
So...
So let's see, I'll write 1.7...
These two capital Es,
that's times ten to the...
So, times ten to the, not the fifth,
the negative fifth power.
Now I want to take log, base ten,
that's this button here.
If you're calculator just has a log button
that defaults to base ten.
So I take log, base ten, of that.
And then I want to take
the negative of that.
And so this is going to
be, approximately, 4.77.
So, this is approximately,
approximately, 4.77
So, the pH is equal to the p-K-a
which is equal to that, right over there.